The joe rogan experience. Hey,
did you see tiger yesterday? Dude,
I was watching it while
we were in Georgia.
We were in Georgia for the UFC and I had
a comedy show out there and we were me
and um, Santino or watching
it on the screen. Ah,
on Saturday or yesterday. We watched
it Friday or was it Friday or Saturday?
Saturday. So Friday, Saturday. Then anyone
yesterday. Well, whatever days it was,
right.
I think we watched it two days in a row.
It was in the gym every day we were there,
but then I got home and I saw it
on my phone. I was like, Holy Shit.
I don't even give a fuck about golf. I
know I'm going to speak. How powerful.
I made a comeback, a huge comeback
that, I mean, that's amazing.
Seven years later,
oh my God,
somebody's put on Instagram.
One of my quotes. Oh yeah,
that I attached to that.
It was pretty cool that I
love a guy get look, I love,
what did I say? I love a success story,
but even more than that, I love a guy,
fucks his life up and then gets it back
together again. Story. It's the greatest,
it's the greatest good.
It must feel to that guy.
It's kind on top of the world again. And
then he like, yeah, it was so messed up.
And then the back problems and troubles
and the kids and the wife and the thing
and it just 11 years. Yup.
And he didn't stop working.
He just went to work and went to work
and went to where? He's 11 years later.
And so he went on major championship
recently. Right. Did anyone win one?
It was a big deal. He won a major
championship within the last,
it wasn't a manager, but it was, it wasn't
a major this, this was the first major.
He's one in 11 years. Okay. So
the other one wasn't a major,
but it was a big event. It
was a big tournament. He wins
that whenever I was like,
wow, he might be back. He can, he can
fucking win big tournament's again.
And then he just, Oh,
it was so cool to see.
The crowd just kept building over the
weekend and by yesterday it was massive.
Thousands of people around the
green just hanging on him. Oh,
the relief that you saw just
coming out of him. It was so great.
And then at the end,
like he walks off where as a kid he was
only like 21 when he were on the first
time hugging his dad at the edge.
And now he comes off 11
years later all this time.
And His dad's passed and he's
hugging his child, his son.
Now he's the father in the
same spot. Oh, it was just,
I was trying not to cry the whole time.
Maybe.
Or there's guys or the guys like Louis
C K who's selling out everywhere and
doing great comedy.
Like he can't,
he could sell out fucking staple center
right now, multiple times in a row.
What's crazy is he doesn't want to,
doesn't want to,
it's just too in comedy
clubs just working. Yeah.
He could easily come back like
tiger woods easily right now.
He said something so fucked up too because
they asked me why I did it. He goes,
I like to jerk off and I
don't want to be alone.
I like to jerk off and I don't like to
be alone. Like, oh, and then you know
he's man. Yeah. I mean
he also, he did some creepy shit, but
definitely did, did some creepy shit.
I don't approve of it,
but he didn't molest anyone.
I don't think we know exactly
what happened either. I don't,
I can't say too much because I don't know,
but I think he did some regrettable
things and I think he would admit that,
but I don't think he did what a lot of
people are claiming he did in terms of,
that's what I've heard,
how often he did it or who he did
or what the circumstances were,
but it was either way.
There's no defending when it
was bad. No, it's not good.
There's no difference.
It's a terrible thing to do,
but what's the punishment for that?
You know,
how much I should punish or did he
not pay for it? He lost all his jobs,
lost all his TV deals,
$35 million in a year of work.
And people still were saying
no, but he's still, he's fine.
I've heard that argument that he's
fine. Like what? These are also,
these are also things that he did like
more than a decade ago. Right. What,
when do you offer someone compassion?
Like when do you,
when do you let some explain themselves?
When do you,
when is it enough is enough for,
should he have to do something?
Like what would people like someone to do?
Well I think they're coming because
there's only a year and that he's back and
killing it because he's so good at comedy.
Cause like with tiger was right,
people hated tiger.
Well there was that,
but there was also the material
that got leaked when he came back.
So people were upset at the jokes.
The parkland joke. Yeah. Not the best.
That shit falls in line with how
he's always done jokes though.
I tell him whether he did this or not.
He says the fucked up thing to say.
It's part of what makes him really funny.
And he does that in real life too.
It's not,
it's a style of comedy man.
I mean it's just like a Quentin
Tarantino has a style of making movies.
His style of comedy is
to say fucked up thing.
So that compounded the fact that people
were upset at him that a year ago,
you know, he said he was going to take
some time off and it's, um, I don't,
you know,
I think it's really important to know
that I don't know what happened and,
and you know,
he knows and they know and it's,
it's never good when someone's upset
that you jerked off in front of them.
That depth.
[inaudible] which is never good for
anybody but also him losing $35 million in
only being out a year. I think people are
set. That was such a quick turnaround.
Like if we're food Tj, is that a quick
turnaround man? I mean, not as a comic,
but for, to the, to the uh, normal
person like a year. That ain't shit dude.
My natural links in,
you know,
if you're getting interviewed and
some fucking idiot comes here in,
cuts your any rear off. Oh, you should
get punched or slapped upside your head.
You know, that'll teach you respect
not to do it and nobody else again,
I should immediately done it, but I
didn't. I answered his question politely.
Maybe. Maybe now he goes on to say,
shut up after that. I can't take that.
My daughter might be
watching this interview.
I'm been telling her stand up
to bullies your whole life.
Don't go running into somebody and tell
them the song. So it was picking on me.
Handle it yourself.
That's what's wrong with this country.
I think with this whole, somebody
picks on you. Go tell somebody else.
I'm not going to tell authorities
this hooligan speaking on me.
I'm going to handle it myself, you know,
because I'm going to see him again.
He's going to think he could pick on me.
Gotta handle it myself.
You know I'm in my interview,
man. You're gonna steal my moment.
I just worked out here.
Just kicked some butt out here.
You barely want to split
decision in your own country.
I knocked this dude out and you're
trying to steal my shine like this.
That's what I'm saying. And then he
got famous off though, which I hate.
So only thing I could take
back about that night,
that it wasn't filmed that and filmed
it, it'd be even better. You know,
he was just gone off and sign this,
you know neon got his ass.
I think it helped you too. Did it help me?
Yeah, but helped him more than anything.
It helps people know who the school
dollars. Mazda DOL doesn't take any shit.
People have known that since
before rainbows had color.
They already knew that they didn't,
they didn't need to see you open this
to the lingo that they like to see it.
They'd like to get remembered, Huh? Yeah.
They like to see people
have consequences for shit.
Talking in this weird era of
constant shit talking, you know,
I think people enjoy it. They like
it. And if you guys ever fight,
but makes it a bigger fight for sure.
I guess you know me guess but
does that like I beat number city.
I've been in this sport for a while.
I've been beating up guys.
Would that validate them to fight anyone?
He has a beat in a top 10 guy.
You still yet to be the top thing guy,
you know like,
but he could get that fight off that that
that's the new age and era they, right,
right. That's a concern. That's a concern.
I'll fuck when when his,
when he's beating in a top Tim Guy,
I'm going to be the first guy
to expose him to break his face,
but until that moment comes you're,
you're talking about the business side
because you already saw on the personal
side any day of the week I will
address you, but on the business side,
get to my level buddy, put in the
fucking world. Go beat a top 10 guy,
knock him the fuck out.
Did you talk at all about getting in
trouble for punching someone in another
country? I was scared out of my fucking
life, Joe. That's what I'm thinking.
I was scared of. I thought this
guy was going to kill me, man.
I might've not looked it, but I was
scared of, of my life. Yeah, I get it.
I'm very cold blooded. You know,
I get that from, from genetics,
from my pops in them.
But I was scared out of my mind.
I thought this guy was going to
take everything I had. You know,
you had to do that. I had to
defend my side. I understand,
but did you worry at all about them
arresting you or any weird shit like that
over there at me? You're in another
corner to press charges. Ah, I,
that's how scared I was.
But I'm not gonna pitch charges
because I understand how my man, yeah,
but that's how I felt.
I've you, you're in danger.
I was fucking hell of in
danger and we just do not see,
it was not just one assailant and he's
just him and his crew of hooligans,
hooligans, lawless people.
I had to defend myself.
I did everything in my
right to defend myself.
There's one against like three or four
dudes and they know it. It's on video.
There's no such thing as a perfectly
fair competition that will be designed by
God to be perfect and be perfectly fair.
Right?
We're always making choices about what
kind of competition we want to have and
what, who we want to allow
into and what sort of outcome
we want to have. You know what I'm
in, right? Just like in baseball,
too many home runs move
the mount up or down.
You know how they changed the rules a
little bit cause they want more home runs.
Same thing with same thing
with track and field.
We changed the rules a little bit to allow
this person and not allow this person.
Right. I think that when
we're talking about people,
we should always try to include
more people, not less. We should,
you know like if and if hey,
if you're a double amputee and you can
get your way into the Olympics and you
can make a plausible case,
I think we should try to entertain that
notion and we should try to find a way
to get that guy in there. Right. As
far as trans athletes go, you know,
we could have,
we could sit here and talk for three
hours about like all the different ways
that hormones might affect your body.
It might not affect your body.
And I'm not an expert on that and
I don't want to claim to be right.
But a sports with a
trans athletes who are,
uh, you know, competing with the, you
know, with their gender, right? That's,
uh, that is a sporting world that
I'm Morgan trusted in. Right.
And I think we should find
a way to make that happen.
I know it's gonna be really complicated,
complicated and messy, right? Um, and, uh,
there's gonna be a lot of debate about
it and there's going to make it can be
uncomfortable. You know, there's gonna
be a lot of arguments, but, you know,
I hope that that's the world that
we've moved forward to. That's my,
that's my point of view.
My point of view is that there's a reason,
there's a distinction.
There's a reason why we make the
distinction to have male athletics versus
female athletics. The reason is
that males have a physiological,
physiological advantage over women. So
in most sports, most physical sports,
we do not have males compete with females.
The question becomes when someone who
is male transitions and becomes female,
do those same physiological
advantages apply?
And what are the, what
is the evidence? Well,
the evidence and competition seems to
be that it shows that it does apply,
particularly in weightlifting,
rugby, mountain biking power,
heavy sports that are,
that favor larger people,
stronger bodies,
males that transition to females have
a significant advantage and they're
breaking world records.
So if you're a woman and you're a natural
woman and you don't take any extra
hormones or male hormones,
you're not taking steroids or any
sort of performance enhancing drugs,
you're doing your very best to
compete in near the top of the heap.
But then someone comes along that was
a man for 30 years and decides that
they're going to be a woman and this has
happened and literally transition a few
months ago and compete as a woman and
destroys records and dominates you in that
sport.
That's bullshit.
And that's not competing
on a level playing field.
That's a person who is biologically a
male and who was a male for 30 plus years
of having testosterone run through their
body and affect their tendon strength
and affect the shape of their bones and
the mechanical advantages of the male
hips versus the female hips and then
they're competing with smaller people who
have been a woman their whole
life. It's not fair. It's,
it's is as much cheating as taking
steroids when the other person doesn't or
taking performance enhancing drugs
when the other person doesn't.
Maybe even more so
maybe in more so because you also have,
there's a bunch of advantages in terms
of reaction time that males enjoy.
It's like it's some significant difference
in reaction time between males and
even untrained males versus
female professional athletes.
But I see him out of beginning
of my guys call it career.
Like I used to not prepare at all.
I was still drinking and using.
I've got up on stage at trop shit up
again to confrontation like am when to say
truck shop. I'd take up animals, shit
part animal parts. I'd got from bookshare.
It's like, like a skull. We've all meat
and stuff and sinew on it. Chop it up.
Fry Nunes released locusts gain to
confrontation like so. Yeah, exactly.
The reaction you're having this
direction they were hacking.
Last I saw was the frame road.
I had like fights.
I've got scars on my body from bad
standup gigs from a time where I'd go to a
confrontation, like I was making a
point about pedophilia saying, oh,
we're all one cultural mind.
So when a particular P to file
is transgressed against a child,
we're all responsible. People are like,
what the fuck? I haven't messed up.
So I got the shit kicked out.
Well that time,
you know I've still got the scar
on my leg that happened there.
Ed and Brian Scotland.
People didn't take it well,
but what I was trying to do
was like create, I didn't
have the skills, the chops,
the experience than jokes.
So is so under equipped,
but like what I was trying to do was
create environments that felt you,
I'm much better at doing that now.
I can create that kind of an uncertainty
in a room or kind of a sense of chaos
and what's happening
and then bring it back.
I hope to a humorous conclusion where
people feel safe and amused and all of
that kind of stuff. Now I think it's, you
can like, cause I did cry and do that.
And comedy clubs and yeah, it was
confrontation. It's done what people want.
So don't you think that by
prepping your stand up in those.